mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
wir sind heute anlässlich der
historischen wahl auf dem campus eines
amerikanischen elite internats in tessin
[Musik]
und verbringen die aufwühlende wahlnacht
mit der amerikanischen sängerin und wahl
schweizerin
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz
ja genau hier war ich vor vier jahren
bereits zu besuch im amerikanischen
elite internat in montagnola die
american school of switzerland ein
luxuriöser campus und bereits damals war
ich überrascht wie sehr sich die
spaltung der amerikanischen gesellschaft
auch hier zeigte unter den studenten
nichts lieber nicht keine ahnung
als lehre versuche ich im unterricht
neutral zu sein aber ich persönlich habe
so clinton gestimmt jetzt sind wir
wieder hier und möchten wissen wie die
studenten jetzt auf ihr land schauen
sonja wie kann das land jetzt die
spaltung überwinden
ich denke wir brauchen einfach einen
starken präsidenten ich denke das würde
helfen die probleme die wir haben zu
lösen
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass der künftige präsident
mit dem was er weiß und was er tun kann
ehrlicher ist so dass ich das gefühl
habe dass er die menschen wirklich in
seiner entscheidungen einbezieht
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass die usa den werten
gerecht werden können auf denen sie
aufgebaut und gleichheit und freiheit
denn wie wir dieses jahr bei der
bleiplatte bewegung gesehen haben werden
sie gleichheit und freiheit für schwarze
amerikaner nicht gerecht ich denke wir
müssen zusammenkommen und verstehen dass
wir alle amerikaner sind und wir müssen
uns vereint uns darauf konzentrieren den
gemeinsamen feind zu bekommen
sie fällt das virus sind gebrauchen
stimmen und von menschen die miteinander
über ihre themen sprechen anstatt sich
gegenseitig anzugreifen
online oder wie auch immer was sind ihre
hoffnungen und ängste für die zukunft
ich hoffe dass wir uns als bürger der
vereinigten staaten vereinen und ich
denke dass wir sobald wir dies tun alle
möglichen probleme im land lösen
aber ich befürchte dass wir zu weit in
diese spaltung hineingeraten sind dass
wir dann nicht rauskommen
die spaltung des landes die korona krise
die verdrängte klimakatastrophe
das sind die zukunftsthemen die die
studentinnen und studenten hier
beschäftigen wie thematisiert der dekan
im unterricht einen tiefen graben der
die usa spaltet
[Musik]
meine aufgabe als die kran ist es hier
ein umfeld der integration zu schaffen
aber wenn unsere studenten schauen was
in den usa passiert finden sie nicht
unbedingt diesen eindruck dass
amerikanische schule habe ich versucht
die schüler davon zu überzeugen dass
inklusion
es war vielleicht nicht etwas ist was
wir vom präsidenten vorgelegt
und ja es ist schwieriger die schüler zu
überzeugen wenn sie die situation in den
usa leben
insbesondere mit der präsidentschaft die
eine spaltung forciert weil trump ihr
student wäre würde wahrscheinlich wieder
schicken rausgeschmissen wie emotional
diskutieren die studenten politik ich
war überrascht von der
widerstandsfähigkeit unsere schüler
während der chor wie die epidemie mit
der wir konfrontiert sind
aber sie sind immer noch emotional ich
denke dass unbekannte die wahl mit
reduziert emotionen
jeder der diese wahl verfolgt eine frau
die ganz sicher wieder demokratisch
gewählt hat ist die sängerin rene russo
die ehemalige vertreterin der demokraten
in der schweiz ist mit den großen der us
politik auf du und du wir haben sie
bereits vor vier jahren durch die
wahlnacht begleitet damals reagierte sie
bestürzt auf den ausgang der wahl
traurig wütend im seele ganz tiefe lebst
auch dieses mal haben wir uns an ihre
fersen geheftet eine schlaflose nacht
mit einer frau die genauso
leidenschaftlich politisiert wie sie
senkt
[Musik]
rene russo sinkt die black mesh momenten
die hülle des schwarzen amerika ein
statement
si
solange strom ins amt ist ich weigere
mich zu löschen
die us amerikanerin lebt seit über 30
jahren in der schweiz die demokraten
arbeitet als backgroundsängerin wie hier
für den schweizer sänger giovanni
georgie
[Musik]
london
im us wahlkampf vor vier jahren war sie
die offizielle vertreterin der
demokraten in der schweiz machte sich
für hillary clinton stark jetzt schlägt
ihr herz für joe biden wichtig ein herz
für menschen egal was man wo haben ist
oder oder mann oder frau oder was ist
also sein herz ist das was ihn ausmacht
wir begleiten rene russo durch die
wahlnacht
sie hat ein paar medienleute eingeladen
und wegen kubi 19 uhr zwei gute freunde
aber auch in kleiner runde wird
leidenschaftlich mitgefiebert schuhsohle
handschuh beiden mit 19 an ihrer
universität kiel trifft im politiker
danach immer wieder bei der politischen
arbeit rasch wert in dieser nacht klar
es gibt ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen
trump und beiden
[Musik]
egal
da
zur stärkung gibt es kaffee
[Musik]
ich habe meine für meine ins land
gerufen
wir haben alle ihre handys ausgeschaltet
[Musik]
dort kam eine frau
maradona
und dann um 525 endlich die erste
richtig gute nachricht für die stolze
demokrat
doch um 35 war noch nichts wirklich
entschieden und rene russo ernte noch
nicht zu welcher zitterpartie
diese wahl noch werden würde
[Musik]
das war unsere wahl nach mit rene russo
ein gespräch mit ihr sehen sie später in
der sendung ja das epizentrum des
amerikanischen kulturschaffens ist do
your gabe von big apple bleibt mit
corona nur wenig übrig vom broadway bis
zum metropolitan opera alles geschlossen
die letzte hoffnung ein machtwechsel in
washington was das jetzt bedeutet wir
haben antworten
das wäre new york was wäre die welt ohne
die new yorker philharmoniker die worte
waren chaos das pathos zu spüren und die
verzweiflung
wir wollen die löhne der musiker
bezahlen die diese konzerte aufführen es
war ein hilferuf der direktorin eine
traditionsreiche institution zu retten
die new yorker philharmoniker haben den
bürgerkrieg überlebt
zwei weltkriege und den elfter september
das war im juni jetzt mussten die
philharmoniker alle konzerte bis
nächsten sommer absagen
[Musik]
die hauptstadt der us kultur steht still
ein ende der krise ist nicht in sicht
mit der wahl eines neuen präsidenten
hofft man auf mehr unterstützung aus dem
weißen haus
[Musik]
auch der star counter tenor anthony
costanzo musste für dieses jahr 80
auftritte absagen
stattdessen macht er mit den new yorker
philharmonikern kleine konzerte in den
bezirken new yorks
[Musik]
aufzutreten vor ausverkauften rängen in
der metropolitan oper und dann
arbeitslos zu sein
thunfisch aus der dose zu essen ist eine
sehr irritierend erfahren aber meine
haltung ist solange ich ein dach über
dem kopf habe um zu essen machen wir
weiter
costanzo spielt mit den new yorker
philharmonikern die freigestellt wurden
alle leben sie von arbeitslosengeldern
die sie knapp über wasser halten
doch wie lange noch
[Musik]
der nächste präsident wird enorm wichtig
sein wenn beiden ins weiße haus einzieht
dann haben wir eine komplett andere
unterstützung für die kultur wenn trump
gewinnt dann sind wir wie man so schön
sagt aufgeschmissen
auch für das metropolitan museum sieht
es nicht gut aus
von den jährlich sieben millionen
besuchern ist es noch ein bruchteil
das sind entgangene erträge von 150
millionen dollar
und obwohl das museum mit einer
milliardenschweren stiftung ausgestattet
ist die entlassungen ließen nicht lange
auf sich warten
vielleicht drei für eine längere zeit
reduziert ist das natürlich auch eine
andere personaldecke auch nur braucht
das insofern eine ganze reihe von jobs
vielleicht auch obsolet sind für eine
ganze zeit lang und dass wir auf der
anderen seite auch einsparen müssen und
zwar jetzt nicht nur für die nächsten
sechs monate sondern auch für die
nächsten zwei drei jahre 4000 museums
jobs sind im staat new york in diesem
jahr verloren gegangen geplanter
hilfspakete aus washington stecken im
senat fest bis der präsident gewählt ist
die museen werden sich etwas überlegen
müssen damit nicht noch mehr leute auf
der straße landen veräußern können um
auch operative kosten zu unterstützen
jedes museum sollte das nicht vollkommen
ausschließen denn wir wissen jetzt noch
nicht was in den nächsten
12 18 24 monaten uns bevorsteht
ein düsteres bild malt auch login vom
new yorker thinktank center for future
er analysierte den einfluss der pandemie
auf kleine und mittlere theater und
ausstellungshäuser wir sind an einem
wendepunkt organisationen dieses kraft
richtung sommer geschafft haben müssen
weitere monate ohne einnahmen auskommen
gleichzeitig stapeln sich die rechnung
von fliehen hören wir sie nicht wissen
ob sie es bis ins nächste jahr schaffen
werden
am meisten leidet die darstellende kunst
der gesamte broadway ist lahmgelegt
tausende von schauspielern musikern und
bühnentechniker sind ohne arbeit und das
sicher bis im frühling winter is coming
die wahl des präsidenten wird
entscheiden wie hart er wird die
kulturelle spitze der usa zu
unterstützen sollte keine frage der
partei sollen doch ich weiß die wahlen
werden tiefgehende konsequenzen haben
für die klasse nicht nur wer der nächste
präsident sein wird sondern auch wie der
kongress zusammengesetzt ist wird einen
dramatischen einfluss haben
ob und welche hilfspakete gesprochen
werden
die neue regierung wird handeln müssen
denn ohne kultur und vor allem ohne die
kulturschaffenden wird new york nicht
das bleiben was es bisher war das
epizentrum der kreativwirtschaft
[Musik]
ja für den amerikanischen präsidenten
gibt es einiges zu tun
die usa ein gespaltenes land donald
trump hat diesen zustand befeuert die
anfänge reichen aber weiter zurück davon
erzählt der us-amerikanische
theaterautor und pulitzer-preisträger
achter in seinem ersten roman den er nun
vorliegt er sagt er musste ein buch
schreiben das auf zeigt wie zerrüttet
amerika heute ist
new york amerika
sehnsuchtsort heimat was wenn man in
dieser heimat plötzlich als feind gilt
wenn dieser sehnsuchtsort zu zerfallen
und beginnt davon erzählt der große
roman homeland energie klagelieder für
eine verlorene heimat geschrieben von
wired achter weltweit ein gefragter
theatermacher als der us-amerikaner 2018
mit den schreiben beginnt sprudelt es
nur so aus ihm heraus alles scheint im
niedergang
ungefähr ein jahr nach trans
amtsübernahme merkte ich dass ich in mir
etwas zusammenbraut
meine mutter war gestorben mein vater
zeigte zeichen des verfalls des schweren
alkoholismus und rampen unser präsident
um mich herum erlebten so viele freunde
und verwandte schwerwiegende
veränderungen zum schlechteren
plötzlich hatte ich das gefühl ich muss
ein buch schreiben das zeigt was aus
amerika geworden ist
erzähler des romans ist er selbst hat
achter er schreibt vom sich von seinen
eltern einem ärzte ehepaar das vor 50
jahren aus pakistan einwanderte
was ist wahr was ist erfunden
autobiografisches vermischt sich mit
fiktion
die mutter hadert mit der neuen heimat
der vater aber will nichts mehr als
amerikaner werden
und er trifft einen der für ihn amerika
so sehr verkörpert wie kein anderer
[Musik]
als der vater donald trump in den 90ern
tatsächlich kennen lernt ist dieser
reicher unternehmer der auch mal pleite
geht um danach noch reicher zu werden
hier kann es jeder schaffen sagt der
vater
hier kann ein idiot präsident werden
sagt später der sohn
der vater ist herzspezialist auch er
wollte reichwerden probierte es mit
riskanten investitionen und scheiterte
eines tages lässt ihn donald trump nach
einem zusammenbruch einfliegen
der arzt ist berauscht von luxus und
macht seines patienten aber auch von der
person jobs selbst
[Musik]
im roman verliebt sich mein vater in
eine vision des amerikanischen lebens
die donald trump verkörpert an er hat
schulden getriebener individualismus ein
zuerst mich dann die gemeinschaft
[Musik]
mir scheint dass wir amerikaner alle zu
donald trump geworden sind ich wollte
die wirtschaftlichen veränderungen
beschreiben die diese gesellschaft
hervorgebracht haben und den schaden
zeigen der dadurch entstanden ist und
zwar aus einem persönlichen blickwinkel
nicht nur seinem gesellschaftlichen
charakter beschreibt diesen niedergang
während die politik konservative werte
beschwört sorgt sie in der realität für
einen turbo kapitalismus beispiel laden
kennen
früher wurden fusionen oft untersagt ein
marktanteil von 8 prozent galt schon als
monopolstellung
seit den 80ern aber durften sich die
großen ketten grenzenlos marktanteile
einverleiben lokale geschäfte gingen
kaputt
überall entstanden bilde gegenden mit
hoher arbeitslosigkeit und prekäre
beschäftigung
die steuereinnahmen sanken das
gemeinwesen wurde aus gehüllt da hatten
sie als langzeit rezept für eine
katastrophe
die wut der zahlen und die tief
greifende der wunsch etwas zu zerstören
ist von diesem nährboden zerrt donald
trump
ach da spiegelt die misere eines ganzen
landes im intimen geschichten
das macht diesen roman so packend
am 11 september 2001 ist der erzähler
auf dem weg nach downtown manhattan
[Musik]
noch in der rauchwolke stellt er sich an
um wie viele andere blut zu spenden
aber er wird beschimpft als arabischer
moslem einer schreit wir wollen dein
scheiß blut nicht
er lässt sich ein wein trend und gelangt
schließlich in einen laden wo er eine
kette mit kreuz stiehlt die er
monatelang tragen wird um nicht als
moslem identifiziert zu werden
[Musik]
eine ganze generation muslimischer
amerikaner habe seit nine eleven in
diesem land keine chance mehr schreibt
achter doch meinte auto das wirklich so
drastisch ich kann nicht glauben dass
wir diese unterhaltung 19 jahre nach
nine eleven fühlen
das passiert schon seit 20 jahren als er
mich zu fragen ob das realität ist
bedeutet dass man grundsätzlich nicht
versteht wie sich die welt verändert hat
und nicht nur für moslems für alle von
uns wenn die weltordnung jetzt
kollabiert wenn über kriminelle an die
macht kommen wenn die wirtschaft
abkommen der nachkriegszeit zerbröckeln
dann ist ein wesentlicher grund dafür
dass die usa diese welt rocken aus rache
von nine eleven zerstört haben das ist
ein grundlegender aspekt dessen womit
wir es jetzt der welt zu tun haben
irgendwie scheinen wir das immer noch
nicht zu sehen
der roman versucht das in allen nuancen
auszuloten
ganz ohne schlussfolgerungen
überhaupt nicht
die usa sind weit davon entfernt ihre
jüngere vergangenheit aufzuarbeiten denn
augenblicklich hält die wahl alle im
griff
[Musik]
si
ja ich bin gespannt worüber achter in
vier jahren schreibt vielleicht über
einen sich versöhnen das land zu hoffen
ist es ich habe mich nach langer
wahlnacht mit rene russo getroffen in
der fotostiftung schweiz in winterthur
dort zeigt die aktuelle ausstellung
bilder von robert frank des vor einem
jahr verstorbenen fotografen mit
schweizer wurzeln darunter die americans
seine serie aus den 50er jahren mit der
er die fotografie veränderte bilder wie
aus einem roadmovie ein düsteres
gesellschaftsporträt das damals ganz
amerika aufschreckte
[Musik]
kein schlechter ort um mit rene russo
über diese wahl und deren konsequenzen
zu reden
[Musik]
wir haben die nacht mit ihnen verbracht
eine schlaflose nacht muss man sagen sie
haben sich zu früh gefreut
nein also war wieso das sind noch nicht
im blick und je nach dem was ich weiß
über das ganze was noch fehlt was noch
nicht gezählt sind bin ich ziemlich
zuverlässig das so weitergeht präsident
es ist hauchdünn es ist ein kopf an kopf
rennen kann man muss man nicht sagen es
ist schon fast ein sieg für trump dass
er so viel boden jetzt hat es gut
gemacht es ist eine schande dass es so
knapp ist also so begeistert vielleicht
nur den tischen schuldenstaaten gewinnen
und sonst gar nichts also das ist so
dass wir müssen uns bangen und so erich
das sagt schon wieder etwas über das
land oder ja was sagt das über dieses
land dass es so knapp ist der weiße
leute haben wichtige angst nicht nur
weiße männer sondern weiße frau war sie
wissen in ungefähr 20 30 dass sie jetzt
denn in dem population minderheit sein
werden
und jetzt versuchen sie lege station und
möchten alles so aufzubauen dass sie
immer noch obwohl sie in der minderheit
sind sie hat immer noch das macht es
gibt bewegung im land auch das resultat
dieser wahl auch wenn wir das ändere
sich dort noch nicht kennen zeigt klar
es ist eine tiefe tiefe spaltung und es
wird sie auch nicht ändern nach auch
wenn schon weg wird sein wird es ist
bleibt er hat uns ganz hat das hässliche
seele von amerika gezeigt was immer noch
nicht geheilt aber ist oder also die
seele von der für die leute der
herübergekommen und
und die uhr an einwohner einfach ins
land weggenommen und die geschlachtet
genau diese seele der afrikaner vom aus
afrika oder irgendwo anders geht und
jene märkte banken haben gesagt okay
jetzt bin ich dein hirn nach einer weile
wenn man andere leute missbrauchtes
frist isele und irgendwann einmal das
sind wie wurm und es muss explodieren
und amerika ist jetzt sein seele ist
eine verrottete seele ist jetzt offen
und jetzt sind alle dass die hälfte der
usa will hierdurch und die andere hälfte
werde hierdurch was braucht dieses land
jetzt weist die kann man nur sagen
können aber eine therapie die usa after
katja flint war also ich bin sehr
traurig weil ich habe nie gedacht dass
nicht ich sondern wir dass gemeinsames
wir in amerika so hässlich war
das ist schon ein schock danke für diese
einschätzungen dank dieses rennens
[Musik]
das war unsere sein und so den us-wahlen
nächste woche das schauen wir wieder auf
die schweiz wie gegen kulturschaffender
mit der neuen corona realität um ich
besuche dann musikstudenten auf der
regel die haben dort im sommer ein hotel
übernommen ich freue mich wenn sie mit
dabei sind gleich jetzt da gehts weiter
mit dem report der markt bis bald
[Musik]
da
toscani
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos